[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm John Burge and I'm the
TL for the predictive analytics
team.
And today I'm gonna talk
about how to do that.
So you're a developer,
you've created your game.
You've figured out how to get
a lot of people into your game,
and now you have to
try to figure out how
to keep people in your game.
So if your game is connected
to Google play game services,
as users are playing
your game, we're
actually building very
detailed time series of what
users are doing in the game.
So let's say that you have
a game about killing zombies
and farming.
So, here's a sample
user in the game.
He's acquired your game, he's
gone and killed 100 zombies.
He's farmed some stuff,
he's farmed some carrots,
and tomatoes, raised
sheep, farmed corn.
But ultimately, he's gonna
end up leaving your game.
Wouldn't it be fantastic,
if at some point prior
to leaving your game, say like
when he was raising sheep,
you could get a signal from
us, that says, hey, this guy's
about to leave your game.
So instead of him
leaving your game,
you can say well, I've
got a golden shotgun.
Maybe I'll give
you a 50% discount
on this golden shotgun.
So instead of
leaving your game, he
picks up this golden
shotgun, and of course
with a golden shotgun,
what are you going to do?
You're gonna go out and
kill some more zombies.
So this is exactly the type
of thing that we're doing.
If you go to the predictive
analytics offering
that we have, you
can actually see
examples of the time series of
real people playing your games.
And you can see that there's a
huge diversity of events that
show up in these time series.
We've got session
starts, any of the events
that you define in your game,
they show up, in-app purchases.
We're working on integrating
crashes and reviews.
General RPC activity,
just tons of stuff
shows up in these time series.
Well, what do we do with them?
Well, we take a time
series and we're
going to want to feed it
into some one of our machine
learning models.
First we're going
to need to extract
some features from that.
And I'll go into some
details about how
we extract those features.
But at the end of
the day, features
for each one of
these time series
just boil down to
a bunch of numbers.
So here you can see, I've got
a bunch of columns of numbers.
Each one of these columns
corresponds to the features
that we extract from
one of the games.
And historically speaking,
we can look at the data
so we know whether or not
someone's turned or stayed
in your game.
So we can label each one of
these feature sets either green
here, for users that
stay in your game,
or red for users that
have left your game.
We take all of the information
that we have about your users,
and we feed it into Google's
Sibyl infrastructure.
Sibyl is a massive
infrastructure
that we have at Google for
learning all sorts of types
of classification tasks.
It's used widely across
many of Google's products.
And now including analyzing how
users are playing your games.
So we take all this
data, we dump it
into the Sibyl infrastructure.
And out comes a trained model.
We do this daily.
And then with this
trained model,
as a user is playing
your game, we
look at the time
series for that user.
Here we have the same time
series that we had before.
We extract features
from it, and then we
dump those features
into the trained model.
And that model's gonna
spit out whether or not
we think that user is going
to churn out of your game.
So how do we do this?
Well, in any of these
classification tasks,
one of the most important
things is always
trying to figure out how to come
up with a set of features that
represent your data points?
Our data points are time series.
And it's really important that
the features that we extract
out of this time
series don't completely
throw away the temporal
information that we have.
So how do we do that?
Well, we define these
temporal windows.
Here I have an example
of one temporal window.
It's the one day
temporal window here.
So we really have two time
frames in this example.
We have the one day window,
and we have everything
that happens before that.
Let's say in your game that
you have an achievement called
the kill megaboss achievement.
If the user killed a megaboss
greater than one day ago,
then a particular
feature gets turned on.
This one that I have
highlighted in red.
However, if the kill megaboss
happens before one day is up,
then a different
feature gets turned on.
So we're preserving some
temporal information
in the features that we dump
into our big bag of features.
Now, technically,
this is something
that you could do on your own.
Although, I'm not
sure why you would,
since we're doing
it for free for you.
But one thing that
you couldn't do,
is you couldn't look at what
users are doing in other games.
So just like we're building time
series for users in your game,
we're building time series
for users in all of the games
that they're playing.
So let's say that this
particular user is
playing three games right now.
He's playing your game,
and two other games.
We can separate all of these
games into temporal windows.
One day ago, two days
ago, three days ago.
And we can look, for
instance, at what's
happening three days ago.
Well let's say three
days ago, the user
triggered four different
events in your time series.
But, he was playing two other
games, and in those other games
he triggered a total
of seven events.
Well these are
just more features
that get dumped into
our big bag of features.
In addition to the features that
we get out of our time series,
we actually have a tremendous
number of nontemporal features.
Player demographics, mobile
device, Android version,
game genre, country, language.
All sorts of stuff.
And you can see now that our
bag is getting really, really
full of these features.
But luckily, Sibyl can deal
with a very large number
of features.
So in conclusion,
if you want to get
these type of powerful
predictions from us,
all you have to do is
connect to our Game Services.
The more signals that you
give us, the better we can do.
We currently have two models
that we make predictions on.
Churn prediction and
spend prediction.
We're busy working
to make improvements.
We have two more models, big
spender and lifetime value.
And we're investigating
other ML technologies
that we have at
Google, such as Google
Brain and other neural
network solutions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]